hi whitneyhl thank you for doing this of
course you believe ten years since the
start of the show I honestly can't
what's your name
Whitney Whitney yeah how did you get
cast on the show so it all happened
really organically I applied for an
internship with Teen Vogue for the fall
and they said if you want a job you
kinda have to be comfortable with a
camera crew because MTV starting to film
a TV show here and I was like okay then
I show up for my on-camera interview at
Teen Vogue and Lauren Conrad walks in
the lobby and I'm like oh my god I'm on
her spin-off show this is making sense
like I'm on Lauren Conrad spin-off show
and so it just all happened like that I
just yeah just so you weren't you
weren't cute in until that first meeting
on camera
no no they told me that they were doing
a documentary style TV show about four
girls living in LA doing various things
in fashion and music and entertainment
and I just thought it sounded like a
cool
I don't know a cool thing yeah I don't
want to touch anything because I don't
know what I'm allowed to touch yet
you're fired already you're fired
now I have to ask where you really
interns for that whole stretch of time
we were I mean we were very much
part-time interns we weren't really able
to be full-time interns but we were
called in for various projects that they
wanted us to felt like if we were on a
photo shoot interning we were doing all
the grunt work so proud of you your new
job thank you
maybe be my boss man supposedly and was
your promotion when you were hired on a
real job I wasn't really ever hired by
Teen Vogue there was like one scene
where it was like you're now in charge
of whoa oh okay it was all the same to
me I was never really given any extra
responsibilities got it yeah